started watching YouTube trying to
figure out different ways to try and
navigate myself through the property
world and then I come across one of your
videos click the link went to the crash
course and it was the brr crash course
after one month of being on the brr
training I had an offer accepted on my
first prr that was when I kind of
thought like okay this is serious you've
got four properties that you control and
you do own one property how much are you
making solely on the property business
now it's about four grand five feet a
month I would literally go to work and
work my 11 hours and from six to about
two o'clock in the morning I'd stayed my
essay and then I had about four hours of
sleep when I got back to work so you're
thinking if I buy it for 90 spend 25 on
it that's 115 then refinance it pull out
majority of your money probably fed
house for 4 500 pounds that's sweet
Finn thanks for coming to my house we
got quite a lot in common because you're
in property full-time you're well you're
also a boxer Professor just turning
professional but um you're from
Wolverhampton so uh talk to me a little
bit about how you got into property and
and the boxing and how do you juggle
everything as well man well starting
from property
I first got into it when I was about 18.
um I've always been interested in
property obviously knowing about how
landlords have got so many different
ones obviously I saved up quite a bit of
money I kind of work part-time since I
was 13 you know weekends bank holidays
through the school East holidays blah
blah blah but I kind of saved up money
for a long period of time thinking I was
going to get like a buyer select
mortgage then when I first started when
looking around at properties when I was
18.
um I've quickly came to realize how
difficult it was to actually get a
mortgage firstly at my age and then
secondly because of obviously how high
the prices were but then I kind of
started watching YouTube trying to
figure out different ways to try and
navigate myself through the profit you
will and watch a couple different like
YouTube people doing property and then I
come across one of your videos I watched
like two videos and the first video I
couldn't believe a word you were saying
he was like the one person who was all
up in your face all in the all of the
camera to solved energy and I was like
nah like this can't be it can't be for
real and then the second video I watched
it again and I was like you know what
I'll just go and do it do you know what
I mean and I'll click the link went to
the crash course and it was the brr
crash course yeah went for the crash
course I didn't think he was going to be
there and then you just took Rock till
part of nowhere and I was like oh okay
so I was kind of like locked in then
proper skeptical then bro yeah I was
really skeptical really skeptical
because obviously you've got your own
skeptical mindset but you've got other
peoples as well yeah but kind of when I
went to the crash course got there
um signed up to the brr training first
after one month of being on the brr
training I had an offer accepted on my
first prr and then that was when yeah
that that was when I kind of thought
like okay this is serious like they're
saying a joke so that's when I kind of
signed up to the academy and I thought
that's when that's when everything kind
of started and that's taking place you
know you've got four properties that you
control and you you own one property 19
years old almost 20 now you've done a
lot you've got a nice little portfolio
what kind of how much are you making
then I know you got your box in and
you're also working all the time how
much are you making solely on the
property business now solely on the
property business probably making about
four grand profit a month nice which is
obviously it's really good especially
for my age I'm not finding a wage yeah
that's kind of close to that yeah and
you own a property as well yeah the
property own that's not making any money
yet that's being refurbed kind of like
as we're speaking Yeah and but that one
is going to start that on that 1.1 K
profit a month so that property then
talk to me about that one then so so you
come on the train then you see me on
YouTube you come down to the training
you'll realize that instead of just
buying a property to live in it makes me
more sense to buy a property investment
yeah how did you find it how did you
negotiate it and and what figures I
looked around in my own area first which
is Wolverhampton and looks around in
Wolverhampton and it kind of just got
thought of going up and off a bit you
know because it's a cheaper area and for
some reason I gravitated towards like
South Yorkshire
um and then I started looking around in
Doncaster
and I found a property I went to a lot
of views it went like one and then that
was it it was a lot of viewings
traveling backwards and forwards and
then there was one property that I found
in Doncaster it was obviously really bad
condition
um it was listed for about 100 Grand but
I noticed it was motivated seller so
went to the viewing offered 80 000. had
the offer rejected and then I put an
offering for 90 000 and it got accepted
so it's still kind of like 10 below
market value and then I was kind of like
a position where like I didn't I
couldn't like I couldn't because I had
to pay for it cash I haven't got the
cash one just my favorite cash because
it was unmarketable it's got It's got no
kitchen it's got it had no bathroom yeah
nothing was working so no one would
touch that no one would touch it the
person who was living in it before
apparently was a witch so gee
it's one of them things like no one like
wanted to touch it at all so yeah and
then I was kind of in the situation
where I needed to raise the finance for
it I was looking deeply into a bridging
loan I had some savings already how much
did you have like from your own money my
own money save is that about 30k that's
good though still I have 30 cash you're
one of these you're one of these kids
like me not making loads of money but
hustling and whacking it outside there
was a point of time especially when
covid hit I was in year 11 when covert
hit or just gone into my in sick form
when covid hit all the schools kind of
like it was bit chaotic if you know what
was going on I just literally worked
like seven days a week through the whole
Accord what were you doing I was doing
um because I work for my dad I work for
a family business and we was actually
doing like sanitizing on them like bin
trucks okay because obviously the bin
men have been key workers and we was
just doing like the sanitizing on them
and I was doing that literally seven
days a week and I literally saved it was
Abby I'm not as good at saving now but I
was an avid save about that one
motivated you to be such a hard worker
such a good saver like what what was it
when you were so young like a school I
don't I can't really I don't necessarily
know I think it's just maybe it might be
the people around me like my granddad my
granddad was a really hard worker
um you know my dad's a hard worker maybe
it's just the people around me that I've
got my family that's maybe where I get
it from but I was the same though but I
was at school yeah I used to like iron
my money
I'd work I'd get I'd get I'd sell stuff
to the school maybe tonight give me
money five pounds okay I'm buying it put
it in a suit guys it got too much then I
put it in the bank and I just thought
I'd be constantly looking at my mind I
could cause the ears like when you
that's the worst thing putting in the
bank in a savings account in the bank
and constantly like it's like you're
almost like like you're like you're
crowding it yeah right but you know what
I think for me it might be will you go
to school I got kicked out but I was
good
no it was so good they kicked you out I
know I got kicked out I got why they
kick you out I had a fight because of
you know it was just silliness in school
I got kicked out it was actually when
you win the fight of course it is there
we go but it was actually one of the
best things that kind of happened to me
how old were you when you got Kings out
of school about 15 because volley wasn't
gonna say is when you're not good at
anything else you're good at fighting
yeah and you're good at making money I
wasn't good at school yeah and because I
was staying at school when I was in
trouble and stuff like that when I
realized I'm quite good at making money
I'm like oh my gosh I'm a hard worker I
can make money I was watching it grow
that was like a game to me it was I'm
good at this and my teacher when I was
15 she said to me she saw I showed him
my Bradford and Bingley account and I
was like look man I had about two and a
half Grand in there she said that's more
money than me and the self-confidence I
got from that yeah so I'm good at this
you know so maybe I thought it was 100 I
wasn't I wasn't necessarily good at
school
um you know I just about Passed My GCSE
and I never really liked school either
it weren't my thing and I was just like
you say I hustled hard grafted put the
put the work in
um and obviously kind of saved up a lot
of money I tried different Investments
like crypto I even started like a stock
for shares ISO I put it in there and
it's just like it's very long-winded
it's going to take a long time it's like
what can you do like maybe Drop Shipping
maybe property maybe Forex like what can
you actually do in a full property well
I've got a passion for it and I think
it's about investing in something that
you you know and you want to kind of
learn and you've actually got in an
invested passion for it yeah 100 100 so
you get this house in Doncaster you get
it really cheap because it's
unmortgageable presumably you worked out
the GDB before you're off at 90. so how
much did you calculate the end value
would be 150 okay so you work out the
Envy is 150 how much is the refurb on it
25. okay so you're thinking if I buy it
for 90. spend 25 on it that's 115 then
refinance it and pull out majority of
your money I mean I'd spend about 2 000
on fees as well for like solicitors so I
think think I'm leaving in about 4500
but to me having a five bed house for 4
500 pound that's sweet I'm not
complaining about leaving four thousand
five hundred pounds how are you gonna
get the mortgage at the end though
because if you're only 19 but like are
you old enough to get a mortgage well I
am old enough but obviously there's
guarantors you can put on it to make it
more accessible as well yeah obviously
this is one of the big things like to
look at thinking about kind of like the
exit strategy now you look to bridging
and that was one option yeah you ended
up getting an investor tell me the story
so I think I think few people have a bit
of stories like this so you're kind of
like not pitching the idea so I was I
just happened to talk about this offer
accepted on this property and I'll start
talking about oh because I have family
members like my grandparents talking
about like oh well are you gonna pay for
it essentially and I was like well I'm
just gonna get a bridge alone on it you
know it's gonna get a bridge in line and
and then I'll see see we'll go from
there and as well
risky like yo what are we doing that and
I was like well I started talking about
the deal so talk about how it's going to
be this it's going to be a five bed HMO
or sa I'm gonna leave like 4 500 pounds
in it you know it's a really big house
blah blah blah before it's a nighty and
I just could find it and then I am
talking about bridging they're like oh
that's risky and I was like well how am
I going to afford it and then because
they heard me talk about all the kind of
pros of what it's going to be and I
wasn't directly saying to them I'll put
money into this this is what it's going
to be I'm just talking about it openly
it was like oh well you know we'll we'll
give you the money for it we'll loan you
the money and it's like well I said if
you loan me the money I'll give you kind
of like five to seven and a half percent
on whatever you give me and I was happy
with it because you better than what
they're getting paid in the band exactly
you know what I mean so they was happy
with it and there was investing in they
were putting the money into me which
they thought was kind of like you know
an opportunity to see me like take that
and watch it grow And maybe invest in
the future yeah see how well that looks
exactly and that's that's awesome and
that's the thing so many people think oh
I need an investor I need an investor
but there's people right under there now
who's literally there's so many people
it could be like aunties grandparents
cousins if you like your friend your
friend's dad it could be anyone there's
so many people who have like got liquid
cash and they've just got it sitting in
the bank doing nothing and they're
desperate yeah desperate to put it into
something but they don't have anyone to
trust or they don't know what to do with
it so what tips would you give then
because this is a very delicate issue
when you're trying to get family members
because so many people have got
grandparents yeah parents Auntie's
uncles I've got a bit of money how do
you delicately broach the subject
without
um I'd probably say maybe don't directly
pitch to them maybe just talk about what
you actually want them to invest in
openly where you're just kind of talking
about it or maybe get their opinion on
it maybe get like what do you think
about this yeah do you reckon this is a
good idea this is like a pretty good
like investment when they start talking
about how good of an investment it's
going to be for you they're going to
think well oh maybe I can be a part of
this because they've just been talking
about all the pros for you yeah and then
they've kind of cycled it in their head
where they're like oh this is good this
is yeah I wish I could do something it's
kind of getting them on board with the
Envision isn't it as opposed to can you
invest in your deal another thing that
you did is you took the plunge first
joined the academy found the deal got an
offer on and the offer accepted before
you got the money which is risky but
that's interesting that you did that why
did you go that way around why did you
not get you the money lined up first and
then go forward so one thing is with me
I'm kind of like I'm not as bad now but
I was very kind of like I'll cross that
bridge when I get to like and and I
think that's a good thing in a way but
it's also a bad thing as well because it
can it can lead to where you get in
sticky situations but it's a good thing
because you're not one of those people
who taken a lot of information or learn
about things and then not take any
action yeah I was kind of one of them
where all right boom join the academy
learn what I've got to learn and then
just go out and implement it how did you
afford to join the academy is that from
your service savings yeah how did you
justify the decision to join the it's a
big investment yeah and she was a young
kid just to be better and part of it I
don't know kind of like when I was
making the decision what made me
um join necessarily but a big thing was
I take it back to fighting my boxing
like I'm not gonna go with fighting a
ring if I've not had a coach training me
for four six seven eight weeks yeah so I
thought well if I'm gonna go buy a house
I shouldn't go into it without a coach
training me in property for a couple of
months or something using that mindset
is what got me into getting trained
before I never fight without being
trained or having a coach in my corner
and the academy is like having a coach
in your corner yeah but for property you
know what I mean you've got the mentors
you got you you've got the training yeah
that's what kind of it makes sense it
makes sense and I think it's the case of
every profession you wouldn't be an
electrician without going to college or
a doctor without going to UNI no so it
just makes sense to get trained and
you've got this one deal which is
amazing but you've also got four rent
and rents and you're scaling up as well
doing bigger stuff so how did you get
into the winter event side I think um
yeah so kind of like when I got the BR
because the bro was the first one and I
realized like kind of like okay I've got
this now but it's going to take a bit of
time so I was thinking well maybe I
should start looking at rent to rents
and rent essays and so I started looking
and it was really difficult like I
struggled with that more than the vrr
the vrr took a bit of time to you know
get it lined up get a view in and then
get an offer accepted where it was the
worth the actual price but with the rent
to rent it was so difficult nice and
ridiculous like partly because of my age
as well because I think it's a bit
difficult for people to take it
seriously when you're you're 19 but you
can also make it I think eventually I
actually got it to play in my favor
um I must have made about 180 phone
calls was before I got my first rent to
rent yeah 190 actual conversations or
dials like 180 like conversation and you
got rejected or did they just fob you up
I got rejected like every time it was it
was either rejections or I actually got
to the viewing and they went with
someone else's application but after
that it's kind of like you get like this
burning like fire inside here where
you're like well why are they what why
am I getting this many notes like you
see people getting their essays you're
like well what did you think when you're
on the academy and every week on The
Mastermind yeah there's people saying
like oh I just got three Deals and
you're like what yeah obviously you like
people seeing people's success anymore
of HDR but at the same time it kind of
like breaks you it's like it breaks and
you're like looking and you're like he's
got like three five rents essays they've
got a little thing yeah I've been on it
like near enough the same time he has
like what am I doing wrong and it's like
well you know you get this fire inside
here the burning fire and you're like
well you know I'm just gonna I'm gonna
to go both to the walls and just go
through and I kind of just ended up
going into walking into letting agent
offices talking to them and I use my age
in my favor essentially because I was
kind of like I was that confident I just
made myself even though I had no like
rent essays I thought well I got a brr
yeah I've got a br I've got some
experience yeah like I was thinking like
well what would a 19 year old has got
like a property so I thought like you
know what I'm just going to use this in
my take it in my stride and that's what
gave me the confidence in I would walk
in there like borderline arrogant like
that's where you Gotta Be You Gotta Be
Like borderline like so cocky yeah
because letting agents will kind of
actually like it because they think so
like much that you're you know what
you're talking about and there's not a
doubt in their mind that you're gonna
mess anything up and they're kind of
buying into you and that's what happened
I kind of I got my first rent to rent
through a letting agent because of those
reasons
um and I asked that little letting agent
a couple of months afterwards call it
why you gave me that property in
Japanese great market research I asked
him why are you going with the property
so I asked him why are you going with
the property I said look look what made
you give it me in the end because I had
nothing
he was like he just said to me he said
to me it wasn't the fact because he said
we've got a lot of applications and we
always get a lot of applications people
want to do rentals and we get like big
companies come to us but he said it was
the fact that it was like you as an
individual like we was kind of putting
our faith into because we loyal to you
interesting we trusted you and you know
we thought we'll take a chance and it
worked out really well and I think
that's what it is I think people don't
invest in your company your business
model they invest more so in you as a
person do you know what I mean and it's
interesting that you said about the
you've got the brr you and I I often say
this about when you when you're trying
to get like regiments or you're going in
cold you've got to think what have I got
going for me yeah well I wasn't thinking
I'm 19 I haven't got this I haven't got
this I haven't got this I think well
what have I got put your best foot
forward put your best foot forward how
did you get around the referencing with
your first referencing you're like I had
to get a guarantor
um I had to use them again I had to use
my nan she's a legend by the way Legend
legend I would talk to the other day I
owe so much so all I think a lot of
people have their motivations of why
they do your stuff but I think the
biggest one for me will always be family
yeah I think that's another reason what
got me to kind of work so hard so just
like
like pay about family and just give them
kind of like everything about what
they've given me in the past that first
runs around where was it Birmingham
Birmingham and was it an apartment house
a house it was a big house yeah it was a
it's a four bed house so how do you rent
do you rent a room by room no no no no I
rent the whole thing it's a four bed
house it's pretty much a five it's
really big it's pretty much like a five
bit how much do you pay to the landlord
twelve hundred that sounds good it is it
is a good price so I'll pay 1200
um and that makes this month it'll make
about three grand profit last month it
made two and a half Grand
yeah but that's what it's probably gonna
make for the next couple months now
because I had I had a direct book in
from a bunch of like contractor workers
how do you Market it when you put it so
I think one thing is what people do
wrong with essays um is that they're
just fling it on booking.com and Airbnb
and just forget about it yeah but that's
like complete opposite of what you've
got to do you've got to put it on
booking.com and Airbnb then you've got
to monitor it on booking.com and Airbnb
every single day right and see others in
the area as well who might be doing
better yours look at what they're doing
but then you've got there's so many
other online travel agencies that you've
got to put it on and then there's also
obviously sending brochures out to
companies and whatnot ringing up
companies one thing as well that I do is
when someone books through Airbnb or
booking.com ring them ring them and ask
them why they're staying mate I love
that especially if someone's booking for
like a week because they might because
it goes back to this someone booked that
four bed house for a week and I rang
them and I said well how come how can
you stand unlock what's going on they
said well we're doing some work in the
area I said okay like how come you've
only worked a week I said oh she
couldn't find any more availability
right I couldn't understand why that was
I think there was like one book in like
a couple of weeks afterwards but all I
ended up doing was I suppose it's that
person I said look like sorry we can't
accommodate it was only like for like
two nights so it wasn't a big deal
canceled that and then they ended up
booking the whole thing then and it
started just call them because that one
booking could have lost me like three
months yeah worth of a direct booking
yeah which is like it all because of a
phone call also you can ring them and
you can say well you can find out what
the company they work for contact the
company yeah I'm sure you do that yeah
fingers with that there's also companies
that are contracted to other companies
yeah so you don't want to ring the
company that they're contracted to you
want to call the company that's
subcontracting them because they're the
ones who are traveling down they're
staying would you say most of your
guests are contractors yeah 100 what
about your other properties haven't you
got four entrance yeah yeah so my other
two there's one in the city center and
then there's another one in Birmingham
as well the city center one that's more
like General kind of like executive
business people than business Travelers
each one has got his own Market well two
of the two of them because I've got two
four beds they're both contractors
because I tend to find that the big ones
are just contractors and then the
smaller ones more of right your
executive active kind of like business
Travelers like maybe Bankers maybe like
International people what does your now
think of how much money you're making on
these deals she just thinks she's I
don't know she just thinks she's a bit
mad to be honest for sure obviously he's
proud but when I tell her she's just
like you know she's just a bit mad I
don't think people can believe it when I
tell them it's my mom may leave like a
bit like because she's got she kind of
like I made her like a bit like a PA in
a way like well she checks on my emails
because I'm really bad with emails and
obviously I'll get like statements and
bookings come through like how much a
booking was worth on my emails and
she'll see all these emails
of like 800 pound 1.6k free all this
stuff and it actually is seeing this and
it's just like she's coming to me and
she's like oh your board's going up now
and it's like yes it is what it is in it
so how much time do you spend on
property versus your job versus your
boxing so with my job I was spending
like 11 hours out of my day to go do my
work when I was full-time boxing when
I'm not training for a fight I'll try
and like you know once a day when I am
training for fight it's twice a day so
boxing takes us some time and then
property I was kind of dedicated like
two or three hours a day when I was
working but one difficult thing I had
was when I got my first rent to sa I was
still in full-time work and this is one
thing you'll have to do when you get
your rent to rent and you've got to
understand this is I would literally go
to work and work my 11 hours I'd get
back about six o'clock and from six to
about two o'clock in the morning I'd
stage my essay get it all furnished and
whatnot and then I had about four hours
of sleep and I go back to work so you
have to be willing to put in the work
yeah man otherwise it's never going to
happen especially when you're doing
boxing job and property top how has he
been on the academy what's the
experience in the Academy online in my
opinion I don't see how people can do it
without the academy like I get a lot of
people coming to me from like one pound
events because I still go there for the
networking tonight I mean it's just the
sick environment yeah you get a lot of
people come up to you from like the
black badge events and the one pound
events
and I genuinely can't like understand
how they can do like all the all the
strategies or grow a business without it
you know I mean you need that Kickstart
you need the mentors you need the
coaching in place to get you where you
want to be and the network man you made
so many friends it's like for example
I'm going into essay management now and
there's a lot of people on the academy
who could do with like someone like me
who've got the expertise with essays to
manage their properties or just in
general like Facebook Marketplace and
other networking events it just allows
you so much opportunity to grow as a
business to grow as a person to network
to actually have friends as well I've
got a few friends just out of the
academy because like-minded people yeah
do you know what I mean how did you find
the accelerated coaching performance
program last month that was sick in my
opinion that's worth like all of the
money you learn to the academy you mean
yeah like order one Airline like just
that why was that so valuable because
it's just like it's a fuller breakdown
of kind of like what you need to do with
your business because when you're doing
your property business when you've got
it to a certain level you know you've
got a couple of to rent maybe you've got
a br or maybe a lease option you kind of
don't know what the next steps are you
don't know whether you should be
carrying on doing what you're doing then
whether you should change strategies you
don't know whether you should Implement
different things and it's like you have
so many different ideas with you when
you go to the acpp you kind of direct
and have that tunnel vision from you to
yeah what you need to do about having a
business yeah and that's all you need
you need someone to kind of direct you
and tell you what you need to do if
people want to get in touch with you
what's the best way to connect Instagram
sorry Instagram is underscore Finn
Cooper and probably Facebook as well
which is just Finley Cooper and yeah
that's probably the best awesome and I
always say to people if you want to
connect with me best thing is to come
down to the property invested crash
course one pound you'll probably see me
there as I'll do some networking
obviously there as well respect brother
nice one I hope you was inspired and
listening to that connect with Finley
come and meet us at the property
investors crash course where you can
spend one day learning everything
condensed into a day about property
investment how you can get started
tickets are one pound but they're
limited so get booked now I'll leave a
link in the description and I'll see you
there
[Music]